avec sa toiture de tuiles et son clocher
dardoise la petite église saint denis
fait la fierté du village des pires i
pourtant à y regarder de près l'édifice
accuse le poids des années
heureusement les habitants ont appris
avec soulagement qu'elle a été
sélectionnée par la mission patrimoine
et va bénéficier d'une complète
restauration
je trouve que c'est vraiment très très
bonne opportunité à c'est une chance
incroyable que ce loto existe c'est très
bien pour le patrimoine communal
c'est un bon point de monsieur stéphane
bern
en plus il n'ya pas de messe en ce
moment donc peut-être avec une
rénovation y aurait peut-être des mais
sans plus l'édifice a été remaniée de
nombreuses fois depuis sa construction
au 12e siècle mais à l'intérieur
fissures infiltration dégradation du
temps s'accumulent plus les mois passent
plus l'église est en danger elle a subi
les restaurations en cours des années
mais c'est vrai que là l'après pas
besoin d'un grand d'une grosse
intervention de travaux déjà une grosse
restauration la couverture donc en
tuiles et le clochard l'ardoisé on a
beaucoup de soucis du métier tel francs
l'eau et et ça c'est grave assez vite
l'église a accueilli le mariage de
vauban en 1660
elle est donc ancré dans l'histoire des
pires i pourtant aujourd'hui difficile
pour la commune de 240 habitants
d'assumer un tel chantier près de 700000
euros grâce au loto du patrimoine elle
va déjà recevoir 186 milles euros
de quoi financer la moitié de la
première tranche des travaux
c'est une bonne chose une bonne nouvelle
d'avoir ce montant et l'église comme
vous la voyez situer leur milieu du
village
je trouve que c'est primordial qu'elles
soient sauvegardés autant pour son
histoire que pour soi sa situation
les travaux devraient débuter d'ici fin
2021 et duré près de deux ans une
souscription sera également ouverte par
la fondation du patrimoine pour que le
grand public puisse contribuer à la
rénovation